[Music]
somewhere between the awful Suicide
Squad and the excellent Wonder Woman a
new DC movie we'll get it sorted down
the middle but when the best comic book
characters ever unite for a film that's
just okay you blew it again how does
this keep happening Justice League in
the midst of a production beset by
tragedy Warner Brothers bravely forged
ahead so executives could keep their
bonuses mixing Zack Snyder's trademark
gloom with the optimism of Joss Whedon
and the priorities of Brett Ratner's
production company who gorgeous that
results in its own signature blend of
orange rods and lots of orange man I
wish they released the Snyder cut also
man I wish the Snyder cut wasn't a
made-up fanboy pipe dream witness a
field that looks like it's being
rendered right before your eyes where
this CGI villain steals the CGI boxes
from their CGI hiding places
uniting the CGI heroes in a big CGI
fight on a CGI battlefield until the CGI
hero merges with the CGI box while the
CGI villain gets punched in the mouth by
the hero with a mouth made out of CGI
yes ma'am ah that just looks wrong meet
the Justice League a bunch of sad losers
are left alone if you stay up here
brooding on the process you know I
wouldn't count on the tribes of men I
need friends who occasionally make jokes
now to save ski
there's Wonder Woman the
three-dimensional hero turned into girl
hung up on her ex I lost someone
I once knew men who would have loved to
fly it when it's your fault they're all
Steve Trevor bro sidon king of the bro
[ __ ]
bomb man cyborg who's there booyah
spider-man who in this movie goes by the
flash Superman and mouth is so
distracting poor Henry Cavill worked out
for months for this role but all I can
look at his weird fake baby mouth they
really couldn't just shave his mustache
or grow up here door you know delay the
movie ha and of course the Batman he may
not be that tough or that smart so your
genius move is dying or that careful
with his secret identity that's like a
bad throw out of your mind Bruce Wayne
firstly he's a Batman that's a bad thing
no that's your oh that's your signal but
wait there's no bud that's a shame he
was the best part of the last one
prepare for the arrival of Steppenwolf
DC scariest Horne helmeted miner God
villain with the giant bladed weapon
since the movie right before this one
he's got a generic look a generic
motivation he lived only to conquer and
super generic dialogue Farnes our last
one it's powerful plans
you're all too weak the ends of one but
no character since Buster Bluth has ever
been this much of a mother lover my
words mother from Army that was it
possible they ripped off everything from
the Avengers except the good villain
come on Joss it's not stealing if you do
it from yourself after all the intricate
plotting of Batman V Superman check out
a sequel that says whoops never mind
pretending Batman knew Clark Kent for
more than 15 minutes from teammates
Clark pretending the world didn't hate
Superman before he died so much
bitterness of course I think it's all
because he's gone
and pretending that bizarre flash
nightmare sequence never happened I mean
that was clearly meant for when this
movie was gonna be a two-parter right so
we're the Avengers felt like the end of
the beginning for the MCU experience
DC's big team up movie that just kind of
feels like the end where they emptied
out their easter egg covered United all
their biggest superheroes and tried
everything they could to make it look
like they still cared you know you can
do this forever I can barely do it now
it's a shame too they were just starting
to take some real steps toward heroism
save one save one person okay baby steps
starring a wad of tin foil scrunched
around a laser pointer
Jason Moana The Dark Knight ow the DCE
you Hunger Games champion super sight I
the voice of Warner Brothers we might
not have thought this through death pool
I mean dead stroke Smash Mouth spider
cars spider car does whatever a spider
car does Oh miles Dyson when will you
learn Mike Pence
speeder Parker and a recast Luthor hey
there for a glass of good a demon oh and
not starring trailer shots and scenes
that weren't in the final movie Aquaman
consumed by water
cyborg as a human and a letterman jacket
the I didn't think you were real she'd
been thinking of real I'm real on it's
useful sidewalk fighting a tank and
talking to a car you should probably
move from flash fighting a para demon
cyborg is a human playing football the
original blue color palette in sequence
Bruce looking at holographic Superman
Barry breaking glass Alfre talking to a
mysterious visitor he's sending scum and
Lois and Clark discussing their
engagement I'll take that as a yes what
Warner Brothers presents Joss Whedon
Zack Snyder's Justice League part 1 of 1
so why does everyone in this movie have
super smelling fear I could smell it
the demons must have caught the scent of
the waterboxx who sent his own you could
smell a story organized that's low
did I not before neato burrito
dude my hammer just got nailed
Elon Musk will create Skynet sweet
dreams are made of cheese Who am I to
disagree a chatter the world and a feta
cheese everybody's looking for Stilton